a surgeon will insert a pacemaker into
your body if your heart's conduction
system the electrical system that makes
your heart beat is not working properly
the heart is a muscular organ with four
chambers
blood collects in the hearts to upper
chambers or atria before filling the two
lower chambers or ventricles when the
ventricles contract blood in the right
ventricle is pumped to the lungs and
blood in the left ventricle is pumped to
the rest of the body the heart has a
natural pacemaker called the sinoatrial
node or SA node the pacemaker controls
the heart rate by precisely determining
when the muscles of the atria and
ventricles contract the electrical
signal produced by the SA node reaches
the ventricles through a narrow pathway
that includes the so called AV node and
bundle branches taken together these
pathways are referred to as the
conduction system of the heart
problems with a conduction system can
result if the SA node malfunctions
causing the heart to be too fast too
slow or irregularly alternatively a
blockage in the bundle branches can
develop causing the heart to beat more
slowly or irregularly these problems can
be due to heart disease medications or
cardiac surgery before the procedure
your blood and urine will be tested you
will also have x-rays taken of your
chest and an electrocardiogram or EKG
will record the electrical activity in
your heart a local anesthetic will be
injected into your skin to numb the area
where the pacemaker will be inserted the
surgeon will make a small incision
beneath your collarbone the Pacemakers
leads will be inserted into the
subclavian vein and then threaded toward
your heart until they reach the right
atrium your surgeon will view x-ray
images on a video screen to position the
leads correctly once the leads have been
tested they will be connected to the
pulse generator the pulse generator will
then be placed in a small pouch that
your surgeon will create under the skin
beneath your collarbone your surgeon
will then sew the incision back together
while you're in the hospital your doctor
will monitor your heart rates and blood
pressure to be certain the pacemaker is
working properly before you leave he or
she will make final adjustments to the
pacemaker settings
after your procedure over-the-counter
pain medications such as acetaminophen
or ibuprofen should be sufficient to
relieve any pain you will not be able to
drive for about two weeks periodically
you will need to followup with your
doctor to test and adjust your new
pacemaker